Nguyễn Hội Quà, có chuyện Anh Vynh Phần Lê, sinh năm 2018, vụ sám ở đường giác tình đặc lắc trong đường hà để từ nếu vụ đảm ất sò tên an giá thông thú hút như sự quan tâm của cuộc đồng mạc.
Chứ dễ vui phòng viên, anh đây cho biết Anh và chỉ buổi thi lợ, sinh năm năm 2018, quanh hào từ thời còn lọc sinh lớp 12, năm 2018, họ tổ chức đám cưới, sau đó, lần lượt 2 con, trái, bái, trà đời, quá phần tạo dụng tụ ẩm thiên trọn về.
Ngày Ngày, ngoài việc quà duyên gia đình, chỉ lơ con còn lĩ sản xem máy mức, chân thủ của tình học thêm đại học mình kể toán kiểm toán để bộ xuống khiến thức, phục phụ công việc của gia đình.
Tưởng chính cuộc sống của họ sẽ mạy anh đêm cho đến mỗi chương ngày 2018, hãy nhá ngăn hành hủ chăm 1 mươi sau khi được công cho tại sế trên đường chương xin đông, chỉ lơ gặp 1 người bạn và nán lại bên lệ đường cho chuyện.
Mất ngờ, một chức xe bụng trở biết tông la tới, tốt chỉ lợ từ vong tại số người bạn đi tương nạ.
Để tưởng nhóm về vợ tình tạo, thủi chung, anh đêm quyết định trong một vụ nguồn vấn mục nghiên cứu ngày trên đoạn đường xe ra tài nạn, cũng trên đoạn đường gái,
ơn một năm qua, anh đã trường hàng phụ vi của khổ thủ, kéo dài cần 1 kêu mê cùng nhiều lợi hóa khác.
Tưởng khóc kây được anh đe trong chút đơn phóa dựng giữa như người hắm tình yêu, lỗi nhớ với người vợ qua cố.
Vình đây, hoa hùng dò anh đe trong lĩnh tiết bị người đi đường đường đường chục.
Đo lòng trước kể anh đa phải vết tâm thư đăng lên mạng xa hội.
Anh chờ rằng, của đời đặc qua với công vụ vợ anh đình phần đời còn lại, anh sẽ chừng lò các con thật tốt để chỉ il lòng.
Anh cũng sẽ chừng xóc của nguồn hoa để đoạn đường vốn đầy đạo thường ở lượng khỏe sắp thực dưới,
nhiều ming chính của tình yêu vĩnh cụ.